- Ideas and making.
Ideas and making.
An idea, make.
Come up with ideas, make it.
I can't even fucking say it.
Come up with ideas and make it.
Fuck the middle.
(yelling)
You got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
♪ We can get lost ♪
♪ Baby won't you ride for me ♪
♪ Everybody ask why I'm so difficult ♪
♪ But nobody take the
time to understand me ♪
♪ Maybe if they did ♪
♪ Then they wouldn't have
to question my time ♪
♪ Gotta draw the line ♪
♪ You get no reply ♪
♪ I been on the road too long ♪
- It's advertising week in
New York, so that's exciting.
I'm about go give a keynote.
And then a deep dive and then
later a panel with TikTok,
so I'll be around here all day
so looking forward to it.
Nothing much more to add,
just a day in the life.
Obviously talks within the industry
lead to a lot of things,
customer acquisition,
customer retention, talent
acquisition, talent retention.
Just giving back to the
industry as a whole.
I like it.
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] You're talking
to TikTok this week.
- Yes.
- What do you think about the platform?
Obviously you're a big believer in it.
- I always get excited
about when a platform
starts hitting tens if not
hundreds of millions of users.
There's actual attention on it
and I'm never scared if it's young
or if it's something else.
What's ironic is the other thing
I'm most excited about
right now is LinkedIn.
I don't care that it used
to be a recruiting job board
or platform or SAS product,
it now is a content hub.
I get excited when something can become
the next YouTube or Facebook.
Whether TikTok goes on and
becomes the next Instagram or not
is irrelevant to me.
The ability to market right
now to Gen Z at scale is real.
Now if you're selling
concrete to 80 year olds,
TikTok doesn't have to be for you.
The reason somebody who's
selling to 55 year old women
as a CPG needs to look at it is one,
those Gen Z kids may influence
the purchase behavior
of that 55 year old and two,
if it becomes a big platform
it's a place that you'd
like to know strategy
and creative about to take advantage.
Whether it becomes Vine or social code
or it becomes Facebook or
Instagram, I don't know,
but it's hit the scale
and the consciousness
that it now deserves
attention and making for it
to learn the strategies
and nuances of the platform
that will allow you to
become a strong marketer
and storyteller when it
hits your demographic
if it hasn't already.
- Okay.
- Hey guys, about to go give this talk.
Thank you.
This talk at Adweek,
but that doesn't matter.
What matters is DRock's
film drops at noon.
(laughing)
- Can't wait.
- So you guys are gonna prompt the video,
we're gonna walk down--
- Yes.
- He'll introduce, okay, awesome.
(relaxing music)
And so I do believe that
the agencies and brands
that most figure out
how to actually produce
thousands of pieces of
content that are relevant
to the most amount of end consumers
that are creating creative
not two-for-one specials,
this is not D-R.
Everybody want to hear
volume they're like oh,
this is good for lower funnel conversion.
Absolutely not.
Yes, it can work.
This is brand.
I mean when is this industry
gonna get tired of producing
an enormous amount of expensive content
that nobody actually sees?
Like what commercials are
penetrating our culture?
Have you ever been to a normal place
and heard somebody talking about a TVC?
Like the stuff that people
talk about is happening
within the Internet and is
happening in all sorts of forms.
I promise you way more normal people
know what the Instagram egg is
than any television
commercial that came out
besides anything on the Super Bowl.
And that's something
we need to think about.
We just need to have that conversation.
I understand ideologically that's not fun
to think about from a creative standpoint,
but we need to go reverse.
We need to be as religious
as the great skill
of writing the copy for a tweet
that captures the attention of consumers
that can then bridge
into a two minute video
that then can be the Super
Bowl spot for that brand.
We need to put that on a pedestal.
We need to put contemporary
things on a pedestal.
Television commercials
were completely shit on
by the ad world because
radio copy was the pedestal.
This is historic.
This is what always happens.
And this is the great advantage,
this is the unlock if you're
curious about the Gary V thing.
One of the things that
is so important to me
about continuously
putting out content one,
clearly through my DNA I enjoy it
and I want to communicate to the world
no different than anybody else,
but you have to imagine how
nice it feels to me to sit
on top of a thousand person
global agency at scale
and know deep down that there
are very few people on earth
that are more of a practitioner
of creative and media
across all platforms than me.
I'm competing with CEOs
that have no context
and that's an advantage and
it's an audacious statement,
but there's a lot of truth in it.
I'm putting out an enormous
amount of content daily
and I'm learning and
it's built on humility.
I never think I'm right, I
think the customer's right
and I just watch what
the customer's doing.
- [Woman] So what's next then?
- What I think is next is doing the things
that are working right now way more.
Honestly I don't want
anything to ever change.
I don't predict and I actually don't want
anything to ever change
'cause I'm good at it.
I get sad when Facebook organic goes away
and I have to find the next thing
'cause I spent a lot of time
and effort to be great at it.
I think the answer is more.
The variable of success
once you understand
the media framework that
you guys are playing in
is the creative variable.
Once you know that TikTok or LinkedIn
or Instagram swipe ups are working
the answer is more contextual creative,
like how many pre-roll podcast ads
are being read by
influencers on their podcast
right now for your business
answer is probably none
'cause I'm not talking
about it a whole lot yet.
Sprinkled in here, there.
But there's probably a thousand podcasts
that you need to hand to hand reach out to
and say how much would it cost for you
to live read about our product.
Howard Stern sold a lot of product.
Listen, if you're Dove
or if you're Coca Cola,
you want everybody in
this room to buy you.
Like these brands want all of us.
Nike, AT&T, Verizon, they want us all.
Think about how fucking hard that is.
It's completely impossible with
a bullshit 30-second video.
Completely.
So now figure it out.
I want all of you to buy a banana.
How many things do you
think you need to do?
A lot.
And so we need to stop
wasting money in meetings
and debating to a 30-second video
and then post-production
matching luggage to that video
in banner and programmatic form
because the KPI is $4 CPM.
Not real life, like we need
a complete re-haul of this industry.
And here's the good news.
It's gonna happen anyway
because if it doesn't happen,
the brands that do the smart shit
will become the biggest
brands in the world.
I want to remind you
that Airbnb and Netflix
and many other things
didn't exist a decade ago
in the way they look today,
so things were coming.
I think we should be on,
I just think of this is
one massive tidal wave
and I think you have a very simple choice.
Do what this industry
does, which puts its head
in the sand and just gets destroyed by it
or find some fucking
surf board and ride it.
♪ You may be gone but so what, say ♪
♪ Look what I've become, aye ♪
♪ Get out of my head ♪
- My man.
- Thank you bro.
Just gave some keynotes,
did an interview for Ad Age,
one of the leading
publications in our industry,
now going to have a quick
meeting with an entrepreneur
that I've been promising for
a long time then going back
then a TikTok session and
then back to the office
and make shit happen. ♪ Like
heard the sound of a gun ♪
♪ But I was tired enough ♪
♪ And closed my eyes for the love ♪
♪ Don't matter cause
it's all over anyway ♪
♪ The same chatter back and forth ♪
♪ That plague my mind like every day ♪
♪ Like how you leave a
person so worthless ♪
♪ Just to stand in rain ♪
- Yo Instagram, check it out.
Gary Vaynerchuk got way ugly.
(laughing)
So good, all right.
- Thank you so much.
- Awesome, take care guys.
- Thank you so much, have a nice day.
- Take care.
Take care.
Max, some of your best
buddies are gonna like
have so much fun with that.
Yo, what's up Twitter?
Is this dropping on YouTube?
- Yeah.
- Only?
- What's good Twitter I'm sure,
I'm going to be tweeting
here, what time is it?
- 11:58.
- All right in two minutes,
in two minutes on YouTube
I'm dropping a film
that the wonderfully talented DRock made.
You know what's funny DRock?
We're hyping this film
and I don't think you started making it
with like this much hype behind it.
- No, I definitely did not.
- So it's like a solid movie--
- An average.
- It's like an average
movie that were hyping--
- Maybe people will watch it.
- Yo, my text homies.
DRock just finished
off an incredible film,
link in the text right now.
Please go watch this, let
me know what you think.
Super excited about it but most of all
on this Monday in the
fall on a beautiful day
you've gotta make a decision.
- Let's go!
(laughing)
- [DRock] Gary, what
are you doing right now?
- I'm sending a text to all of you.
We're a part of the text 212-931-5731.
I was really excited to the
point where I had the numbers
so memorized that I could
drop the 212-931-5731
so fucking quick and easy.
- So you're writing a text?
- Yeah, I know what you're
trying to do like yes,
every text you get for me if
you signed up comes from me.
The replies, the push out,
this is literally me doing it.
I just recorded it and now I'm typing.
Hey guys, I made a film on YouTube
that just premiered right now.
So there's 2,600 of you watching
right now on live right now.
I want all 3,200 of you
to go hang up right now
from the live because
I'm hanging up and...
- Thank you!
- You're welcome.
And...
Hi.
Go check it out, it's real good.
I think you're gonna like it.
I think it's gonna help a lot of you.
I really think there's something there.
Please check it out, you know
we don't hype films often.
Thank you, love you, love you Instagram.
Yo, what up bro?
- What's up?
- How are you?
- Good.
- What's your name?
- Harrison.
- Harrison, nice to meet you brother.
- [DRock] Harrison, where'd you find Gary?
- What?
- [DRock] Where'd you find him?
- On Tiktok.
- [DRock] Amazing.
- Of course.
- Ready?
- Wait, yeah.
- Got it?
- Thank you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Like for example, I think the next one
should be about competition.
I never talked about it.
It'll be a challenge to find shit,
like I believe being competitive
is an incredible advantage
that in our times of
2019 is very balanced,
it's why I care about
eighth place trophies,
if you eliminate the goal,
but I also think the world has abundance.
Like I want to destroy
everybody's face in there,
every agency, but when somebody else,
if Max have an agency and it beat us
or it won the business
that we were both going for
in Adidas I weirdly am happy for him
even though I'm sad for me,
because I love merit.
I love the game is the game.
Like don't fuck with
competition, let it be pure.
Don't demonize competition.
Win at all costs is right in
the framework of business,
but not in life like I'm not
gonna try to hurt Max's life,
but in business I'd be like he sucks.
Like you know?
It's kind of that whole thing,
so I think competition's
something I wanna talk about.
- Why do people blend competition?
Why isn't it pure?
- Well people with power
try to change the rules.
To me like I don't try to like break,
when I get old and have money
I'm not gonna try to change the tax law,
because I'm tired and I'm
scared of young buck killing me,
'cause I'm killing old buck right now
and I should be killed.
That's what I love about like nature.
I love that the old lion
that killed everybody,
when it's his time, gets killed.
And that's where people fuck
up capitalism and competition.
They try to change the
rules when they're finished.
I have no respect for old lions
trying to change the rules of the jungle,
because they wanna keep eating.
It's time for them to die.
Love that about sports.
LeBron's not going to be able to
continue doing LeBron in 12 years.
I love the purity of competition
even at my own expense.
But I think it matters.
I also think we need
to really respect like,
right now we're in a era
where one could demonize
alpha competitive, you know like oh no.
I think balance is everything.
Everything I talk about
is extremes on both sides
and really I don't use the word a lot.
It won't show up in my in my word cloud,
but almost everything I'm
actually talking about is balance.
A balanced conversation around competition
would be a really healthy one.
Anyway nonetheless, that
was obviously a rant,
could produce some
content but once a quarter
and then the other thing I want from you
I thought about this weekend
is I want you to make things
on the spot when I fucking feel 'em.
- Like if you're on stage--
- I can have both of them.
I can have my cake and eat it too.
You're there, you're like
doing this new thing.
I want to make sure like
when we have a real moment
and we all look at each other
I just want to know that's
been made the next morning.
♪ Gas station pop and cigarettes ♪
♪ I like you lots babe, I'm a mess ♪
♪ I be lying out a lot
when I feel stressed ♪
- Tell Andy and Sid and Katie,
let's get a mix up
people, some new people,
four people, nice little mix.
Call Andy, let's get a four
person, five person mix,
I want them to go live on LinkedIn
and talking to my audience
about the film without me there
since they can go live on LinkedIn.
- Yeah.
Here's Gary.
- Andy can you can get five people,
a diverse group of men and
women, all kind of creeds,
and do a LinkedIn live
right now about this film
and say Gary just called
us and told us go live
about this film, here's how we made it,
here's we thought about it.
He's not live because LinkedIn
isn't live on mobile yet,
but he wanted to get out about it.
The link to the film is in here.
He wanted to get behind the curtains
because he hopes it inspires some of you
to make a film for your company.
Bye.
(DRock laughing)
Ideas and making.
Idea, call, make.
Ideas and making, that's it.
Ideas and making.
An idea, make.
Come up with ideas, make it.
I can't even fucking say it.
Come up with ideas and make it.
Fuck the middle.
(upbeat music)
I have to give this talk about TikTok
with one of the senior
executives from TikTok.
Should be fun, right?
I mean you guys have
seen the manifestation
of the beginning of TikTok conversation.
And I get the details
from both the platform
and my perspective in
a super-rad auditorium
so looking forward to it.
(audience applauding)
IMAX life.
I mean it's--
- That was very profound.
- It's historically correct.
All that TikTok for me,
being the first brand
to go heavy into TikTok
that is targeting that demo,
because I still don't fully
know where the demo is,
but let's just say skews younger for now,
is no different than Procter & Gamble
being the biggest spender on television
in the 50s and 60s because
that was the arbitrage
or Wish, the shopping app,
you probably knew this.
I mean this is what Facebook executives
joke about all the time.
There's all these companies and LLCs
that nobody's ever heard of spending
uncomfortable amounts of money
and Coke and BMW are
spending a third of that
and everyone's confused
to what's going on.
To me if you're selling to
15 to 25 year-olds anything
and you don't have an
uncomfortable strategy,
uncomfortable is a slang term for all in,
creating everyday at scale on TikTok,
you're missing one of
the great kind of moments
and the shit can go away.
And still goes with you.
One of things that I'm always
fascinated by is people like
well Gary, what if it
goes away in three years?
I'm like you take the
brand equity with you.
There was a lot of people who
built a lot of brand equity
on Vine and when they started
creating on Snap or Instagram,
the audience, a percentage of it went.
I don't know why everybody's so literal.
You're so happy to mark it on
Super Bowl or on television
or an outdoor, that goes away too,
but there's something
ideological in the system
that has this sad feeling that
it might turn into MySpace.
My preference is that they all die,
because that means the attention is moving
and it will always benefit the quickest
and the people that are most
willing to play that game,
which is my most comfortable game.
I love having debates with
people about the past.
The past is always people's
vulnerability to the current
and definitely to the future.
(electronic music)
What's up vlog?
You know obviously we're
doing a better job now
so I'm just gonna take the camera.
Max is having a weird day
'cause he was told that
he's not as good-looking as
me by me, so that was good.
DRock's probably going through
his own set of emotions
because the films out and
he's probably deciding
what he likes and doesn't like.
I'm never really sure
what Jason's thinking.
That's just kind of how it
is, but it's always good.
Feels warm and happy to me.
Anyway.
Avi, how's traffic?
- Looks good, 10 minutes.
- Good, so it's 2:11, 10 minutes.
I'm getting nine minutes
back, it's a good day.
Give me those fawking nine minutes.
- [Max] Fawking?
- Fawking.
It's fawkers.
You know it is the truth.
Great content always wins.
(DRock laughing)
It's just true.
- [DRock] I'm laughing out of agreement.
- 100%.
You can have the best
mic, the best slides,
the best auditorium, you're
not gonna beat my talk.
And I'm gonna do it on a
cardboard box, a fucking sidewalk.
I did a thousand episodes of
Wine Library TV with no audio.
No lighting, none.
All 1000 episodes of Wine
Library are done a camera--
- [DRock] A handy cam.
- Whatever the fucking camera
picked up, no lighting.
Fucking everybody went out made
highly produced wine videos,
everybody was gonna take
me out with production.
Pfft.
Production never beats story.
- [Max] Why?
- 'Cause the story is the punchline.
Now production can add to
the story like "Avatar"
and "Star Wars" is fucking
amazing but don't get it twisted.
That fucking story matters.
You don't think there's
been highly produced
Hollywood fucking movies made with those
great fucking cameras too that suck shit.
"Waterworld" fucking sucked.
(upbeat music)
- [DRock] Gary and Andy, a different Andy.
- Hey, I know it's a lot.
We come from Jersey Island
and you've affected our whole pathway.
- [DRock] Can you get out of the elevator?
Guys, guys.
- That's awesome.
- A lot.
- That's amazing.
- [Andy] We've built an
environmental curriculum for kids.
- Yes.
- [Andy] And we just
come out the brain room
for the last two years
and we're just here--
- [Woman] Hustling.
- I understand.
Such a pleasure.
So nice to meet you,
yeah have a great day.
Take care.
Here, just take this for now brother.
- What's going on guys we
just got back to the office,
full afternoon of meetings, Monday,
got a lot of work to do, let's get it.
- Text me three or four
nights in New York.
- Yep, I'll put it together.
- Ferg, tell 'em.
Tell 'em.
- Yeah, "Floor Seats" out right now.
Talk to me nice or
don't talk to me at all.
I gotta get you back in the studio.
- Let's go!
(laughing)
All right, I gotta get
back to this meeting.
Hey everybody welcome to a very special
episode of the podcast.
My friend Jimmy is here,
we've met for a 100th of a second
so we're going right into this
'cause I'm excited about this.
Jimmy, I think it's gonna
be really fun for everybody,
please tell everybody why
the fuck you are here.
And more importantly, actually
what I'm actually asking
Jimmy is how did you get here?
Remind everybody on the opportunity.
- I answered the give away
that you had on the text platform.
- [Gary] Mm-hm.
- Went onto Twitter, used the hashtag,
explained you know, I think
there's a little bit about
like you know why do you
want to be on the podcast.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I got a question on
the #AskGaryVee show,
shit, three years ago.
I've been doing a little bit of stuff,
but not like really going
hard at it like I should be
and I just put my story
out there a little bit,
used the hashtag.
- Let me frame it up,
because I'm gonna let
you take over from here.
Everybody who's listening,
the reason this podcast's fun for me
is obviously I've started
doing a lot of text messaging
on this platform called
community that I'm using
and a couple things, one yes it's me.
Every single text, every
single time you get a reply,
it's always me.
- [Jimmy] I believe you.
- Thank you.
That's why I'm using audio and video.
So for everybody's
wondering, it's always me.
Obviously I'm putting out stuff
every day, every other day,
every couple days, but
what I'm obsessed with is
if I'm gonna put out hey,
watch DRock's new movie
or hey, sign up for wine texts.
If I'm gonna be in the
right hook on a text
I think unlike social I need
to be very careful there.
It's a very special
place, your phone numbers,
so I'm obsessed with bringing values.
So I've decided that for
everybody who signed up
for my text messaging
platform it's gonna be
the place where I create access.
- My thing is like if you're working
and you're doing your life stuff,
if you put out so much content it would
literally be like the
same content every day.
- I think it's a really good question.
Couple things.
- Especially if you're wanting to
do something like travel, you know?
- This is tremendous.
This is where creativity and ideas
has to be something I talk more about.
So for example, when I think about
a hundred pieces of content a day
and this is great because it seems like
you're grounded in Twitter more than many
because you were part of that era with me.
I think Twitter is an
incredibly important part
of the hundred piece concept.
Obviously this is catching
and I'm getting asked about it more,
so this is a great opportunity
to create some clarity,
hopefully the team clicks this.
Let's get Rogoff to write a piece,
you know the hundred piece concept 2.0.
I think we're working on something,
but Twitter's incredibly important.
As you know one of the great
things about Twitter is
it's trending topics and
the ability to reply to it
with retweeting and adding your two cents
or typing original thoughts.
So for me one of the things
that really stands out is
if I was asking the normal
quote-unquote person
to produce 100 pieces of content a day,
I guarantee you that I'm
probably subconsciously
thinking that 50 of those are Twitter.
You can write, you can retweet
and add your two cents,
all of a sudden you're kind of there.
The other thing is I don't think
people understand document versus create.
I think people think you need
DRock or Jason following you,
or Dustin following you around.
I think it's just taking a picture,
like I see content right here.
Like I see content and this
is probably my strength,
I see content in everything.
I think you should take a
photo of us talking right now
and tweet it and be like holy shit,
I'm doing this with Gary V right now.
- [Jimmy] Yeah I did, I
took one before you came in.
- There's Madison Square Garden
and like this is New York.
I think there's a lot more
content and by the way,
I think that could be done
15 to 20 times on Twitter,
Instagram stories, and
TikTok without any cost
to the preciousness,
that is the main reason
that everybody can't make
100 pieces of content.
Taking a photo of what you
see and adding one sentence
is allowing people into your world
and you start creating
around common interests.
A lot of people are like Gary,
should I separate my business and life?
I'm like I put my Jets
content in all my content.
I put my garage sale stuff there.
That has nothing to do the
marketing or the business running
like I think it's there,
but I do think it's a strategy mindset
and I think everybody
thinks this is useless
and nobody would care
and I think you should let them decide.
♪ Gas station pop and cigarettes ♪
♪ I like you lots babe, I'm a mess ♪
♪ I be lying out a lot
when I feel stressed ♪
♪ I know I probably sound so pessimist ♪